you're only 20 years old and you've had
so much
bad luck and tragedy in your life
constant
how do you explain that you've had so
much
[ __ ] look making stupid decisions
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time
uh it's
bad luck i guess i asked that same
question every day
you know why me what have i done to
deserve it
all right miranda hello miranda where'd
you grow up where you from
originally i was born in colorado
um lived there about a year after that
my mom and dad and i moved to arizona
and at four and a half my mother left my
father
took me which was shortly after i was
raped by one of my
father's druggie friends at
four years old yeah four and a half um
my mom moved me to kingman
from lake havasu and
we lived in a section eight duplex
i can remember at six was the earliest i
can remember
having to fill out my mom's paperwork
for her doctor's appointments
and helping her with her college
paperwork and her tests and stuff at
nine
um we stayed in that duplex the entire
time i lived there
till i was about 13.
uh at which point i had gone to juvie
actually
for taking the fall for one of my homies
quote unquote um
basically just a person i did meth with
and i took the fall for him and went to
jail the juve jail
stupidest mistake of my life because my
mom passed while i was in there
um i had started meth actually
about 12 years old started by shooting
up
right here in this vein actually i can
still see the scars actually on
both my arms my veins no longer work
they have to find a vein within my wrist
right here
to actually get an iv in me or the top
of my hands
those are the only ones that work hell
do you know
i'm 20 now i currently do
uh fentanyl and heroin
um i started doing fentanyl and heroin
after i lost my my second daughter
um about five months ago
i miscarried at 18 weeks i just found
out that day that she was a girl
her name was shaw day stephanie
my first daughter i had when i was 13
shortly before i went to jail
but i was beaten seven months pregnant
um while i was pregnant
i had done everything to keep that baby
because i'm not going to hurt no child
especially when they got no chance to
defend themselves
you know um but i found out the baby
daddy was doing
heroin so i left him and he beat me
uh he left me there in his own house for
dead basically
i called the ambulance and
passed out after i called i remember
waking up in the hospital
and then putting the baby in my arms
she died 11 minutes later latched on
to my titty to breastfeed
um after that i got
really stuck in the dope for a long time
i went from 140 pounds to 93 in about
three months
i spent
about six years doing that
up until recently i finally started
gaining my weight back
back in utah and
i got sober for a while
for about two years
i was sober and i had a fiance two
full-time paying jobs
and then covered struck
my baby daddy well not my baby daddy but
i called him that
um he got stabbed between the fourth and
fifth row
straight and to the heart i had 37
seconds to say goodbye
um that was one of the hardest things i
went through
after that i started doing dope again
i ain't stopped since just gotten worse
and worse now i'm doing fentanyl
[ __ ] people are dying every day from
that and here i am smoking it
it's like i'm testing fate or something
ain't got no will to die just ain't got
nothing else to do
i'm stuck in the streets doing whatever
i can for
money um i don't hover none of that but
uh
i mean [ __ ] i'll rob people i'll steal
from stores
i do what i have to do to make my money
you know
sometimes i'll get lucky and one of my
homies or something will
come up and they'll share with me but
i mean most days i don't have any money
any food
most the food i eat is passed out from
schools and churches
there's a lot of good people out here
actually that give out to the homeless
luckily
otherwise [ __ ] i might be dead by now
i've been beaten out here for no reason
i've been kicked in the face by a female
because she was jealous of me and so she
made up an accusation
that i snitched on one of her homies so
that
her boyfriend would stand there and
protect her while she kicked me in the
face
in an alley after stripping me naked
and making me squat and cough
nobody did anything about it try going
to the cops about it but
you know how they are they don't really
do much for the homeless
sadly um because once you're on the
streets you're on the streets
you know not a lot of people are willing
to help
but you know
somehow i'mma get there hopefully
you know i did spend four years in utah
that's uh when i was clean
but uh my dad died
september of last year so you've lost
both your parents man
i'm an orphan all my family is dead
uh my auntie died when i was 11.
my grandfather died when i was nine
my grandma died when i was 10.
um my nana just recently died in
december um
my second daughter like i said november
19th
which was right after or right before i
started heroin
um started
fentanyl about a month ago because heron
wasn't enough anymore
um
tell me about your childhood you were
molested at four of it
tell me what else what your childhood
was like
otherwise most the time me and my mother
were fighting
honestly i can't remember one time
that i can say was a good day all the
way through
i remember there was one happy moment
that i do remember with my mom
and it was my seventh birthday and her
boyfriend ended up grounding me
because of some stupid something
and she ended up taking me shopping
anyways
and even though we didn't get anything
you know we were just window shopping it
was
you know she still took me out and we
had fun
uh when i was in rehab actually
right after i was in jail
which was actually where i was when my
mom died not jail
she and i got a lot closer
and shortly after that
we were good for about a month right
before she died
and heard your mom pass away she had
fallen in the kitchen and had a
concussion
and according to the people she went to
school with
they had sent her to go to the hospital
but instead she went home
and went to sleep and she never woke up
and you know i i blamed myself for a
long time because
i should have been there you know to
take care of her like i'd always been
you know i've been taking care of her
since i was six but uh
you know i got too wrapped up into the
drugs to do anything for her
and when i was in rehab you know i
wasn't there to take care of her i
wasn't there to
make sure she took her meds or you know
i wasn't there in general and i should
have been i shouldn't have been out
there doing drugs and [ __ ]
i mean that didn't do much for me
obviously
but get me on the streets
um she had a wonderful smile
i remember that
yeah but uh she did what she could to
take care of me i know that
and even though every day was just
another fight
i realized now it's just because she was
trying to protect me
she was trying to keep me from doing all
the things i was doing and
i just wouldn't listen you know it's
something she always told me
you know you could be a lawyer with as
much as you argue but if you would just
listen for a second you'd be okay
she was right
um i should have listened to her because
she had if i would have
i never would have been on the streets
like i am
you know that's what kids nowadays need
to need to realize is that
thank you it's that they need to listen
to their parents you know
because if they would you know they
won't end up like me
man i hope kids nowadays start listening
because
[Music]
being me ain't nothing to be i'm 20
years old on the streets begging for
food
begging for money everything i can do to
survive
and ain't fun you know like i'm begging
people just to stay alive
that ain't something you want for
yourself
not at all i mean
[ __ ] i was raped twice last year and 19
years old
because i was in a deep dark alley just
trying to get drugs
and uh
you know nobody helps you can scream as
loud as you want but ain't nobody gonna
hear you
and even if somebody does hear you they
ain't gonna come
especially the people on the streets you
know they're they're not gonna save you
they're not your friends you're alone
out here
you have any friends no
i can say i have one friend in my life
and i've known her since i was in second
um her name's hannah she has
a son now mason he's beautiful
beautiful baby boy i miss the [ __ ] out
of that girl
but uh you know she's somebody i always
talk to when i can if i have a phone you
know that
i can get a wi-fi on or something see
somebody always called on that no i'm
okay
it's rough out here man you know
a lot of people don't take the time to
do what you're doing
and to listen
it's not easy being a little
female out here alone on the streets
not a lot of people even care you know
you meet a lot of people who only want
me for my body
that's all they're gonna be interested
in
you know they don't care about me or my
story or what i'm going through all they
want is
that [ __ ] you know
it's it gets old after a while
it's uh
really degrading that all i'm worth to
somebody
is a couple minutes you know
they don't care you know they'll fake
and play games and act like they care
but
they really don't
you know and all these these kids out
here i see kids that are younger than me
out here on the streets and i'm just
like what are you doing
you know like
you could be in school you know drug
free
home with your parents i don't have that
i don't have that opportunity anymore i
passed it up
i missed both my mom and dad dying
you know my mom dying i couldn't really
help missing it but uh
i missed my dad
because i didn't have the balls to go
back and see him
you know i had the opportunity
right before i stepped in that car i
changed my mind
and he died you know i told myself oh
he'll get better he'll get better
but i didn't even get to say goodbye
because
i wouldn't go see him you know and
that's a
that's a decision i'll never never let
go
you know i'll never be able to live that
down
i regret that every day not going to say
goodbye
but in the end the drugs being
ended up being more important
and uh [ __ ] it sucked you know
how are you introduced to drugs at such
a young age
i met this guy at this
church after school church program in
arizona
and you know we had been friends for a
couple of weeks and
i eventually went out to his house out
in bullhead arizona
and we were going to buy some weed i had
114 dollars in my pocket
and uh he ended up
buying meth instead and
so i stuck a needle in my arm
i said [ __ ] it it'll help i was really
depressed as a kid
don't really know what for didn't really
have anything to be depressed about
not back then i mean now yeah but back
then i don't know why i wanted to do it
didn't make no sense
um i was just a really damaged kid
overall
making stupid decisions for no reason
you know just to be rebellious
rebellious isn't something she should be
unless you've got the backup to be
it yeah
how much does that molestation at four
and a half impact your life now
um actually it made me more promiscuous
than anything
um at about 11 i lost my virginity
willingly um
but uh up until that point i didn't let
nobody touch me at all
my mom wouldn't hug me nothing none of
that i didn't
i didn't let anybody touch me
um when i was about 11 i started
becoming curious
and so this kid i went to school with
he was only 12.
we ended up fooling around a little bit
you know
and one night we ended up
actually having sex at his house
and uh i remember he had a
pillow over my face so that i couldn't
see nothing
you know because he was shy or whatever
but uh not to where i couldn't breathe
or anything just to where i couldn't see
and uh i mean
it was it was all consensual and
everything like that it was just
he didn't want me to see his thing i
guess
you know late now it's funny you know
i i i still talk to him
i'll message him once in a while i
remember that green pillow
and we always laugh about it but uh
it was funny um
man but uh
looking back now i wish i would have
waited
i wish i would have saved it for my
ex-fiance
who i ended up meeting in utah
but uh you know him and i still had a
lot of fun together
for about three years we were together
up until he was stabbed died in my arms
that kid was only a kid you know he was
only 20 when he died
what was he doing that got him stabbed
in the heart
nothing he was protecting me uh this guy
was being
really rude and disrespectful
and i punched him in the face
and so he hit me back and pulled out a
knife
and before he could get to me my
ex-fiance jumped in
and he stabbed him right here
right between the fourth and fifth fret
and went straight into the heart
and after your heart's damaged beyond
repair
you've only got 37 seconds to live
and that's a fact that i have learned
from experience
not the internet and that really sucks
you know
for a long time i blame myself for that
one too
i still kind of do you know had i just
kept my mouth shut
he might still be here
but i just had to open my big mouth you
know
say something back and hurt somebody
that i shouldn't have [ __ ] with
but uh you know it is what it is
can't take it back now
but uh at least he's in a better place
you know
better than being on this earth [ __ ]
this place ain't nothing you want to be
with
ain't nothing fun out here
everything out here ain't nothing but
pain misery
sadness i mean i can't even stand to
look on these streets
i feel bad for these people you know a
lot of these people have just lost their
minds
being out here they talk to themselves
i mean most of them are probably
schizophrenic or something
no help out here just because they got
hit upside the head
maybe one too many times i think that's
how a lot of them lose their mind
honestly is just get hit one too many
times and
their mind snaps start talking
themselves
eating out of trash cans [ __ ]
living in piles of garbage
it's disgusting you know
i mean at least me i have some resources
to keep clean you know
got a couple of people that i know that
live in buildings that'll let me come
and shower
you know stuff like that but
still it's hard out here man
you're only 20 years old and you've had
so much bad luck and tragedy in your
life
constant how do you explain that
you've had so much
[ __ ] look making stupid decisions
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time
uh just bad luck i guess
i really don't know i asked that same
question every day
you know why me what have i done to
deserve it
because i don't you know you feel like
life is unfair
no it's not it's not fair but
you can only do what you got to do to
survive you know
thank you
you know you can only do with so much
i mean i have a high school diploma i
finished school with the 4.0 gpa
but getting a job without an id
and getting an id is so damn hard being
on the streets
she ain't got the money for it or you
know even with an id voucher
you still have to have a birth
certificate your social security card
and then even then most of the time if i
have all that
i'm too doped up but my [ __ ] gets stole
so you know it's uh
it's also a lack of motivation on my
part
mainly because i just i don't want to
wake up in the mornings you know
i'd rather just stay asleep what
emotions do you deal with
most depression a lot anxiety
um i have a panic disorder
that uh causes random panic attacks for
no reason
uh like out of nowhere i'll just start
panicking
i'm not gonna be completely alone
and all of a sudden i'll start thinking
which leads me into panicking and
i'll just sit in a ball cry by myself
ain't nothing i can do to help it i've
been on medications all my life
which never really worked
i've tried for years to manage it
and it just nothing really helps
except for the black which the hair on
um the fentanyl helps a little too
but i'm more shy on using that because
uh
i trying to die you know have you odd
one time about a week ago on fentanyl i
took two really really small hits
you know smaller than i normally take
and even that
caused me to od you know um i remember
getting up to go to the bathroom
and i uh
was starting to head back to the tent
and it was only a ten foot gap between
the tent
and the porta potty but
i ended up falling and passing out i
guess
uh that's what these little scrapes
right here are from
and these bruises i fell to my knees i
guess
and just passed out i wasn't breathing
um i remember waking up after my
my friend had shot me up with three
narcans up the nose
and i woke up in the grass full-fledged
into a panic attack
and i remember crying for my help or for
help from my mama
you know mom what's going on i don't
really know
why i felt like i was talking to her
maybe i was when i was out you know
um he told me i was blue all the way
down to my fingers
completely blue from head to my fingers
and uh i just can't imagine that you
know
blue like i just stopped breathing
and i didn't even know it i don't
remember it
i think that's the scariest part is that
i really
i just don't remember
and then coming back you know it's i was
freezing cold
i mean i had cold shakes that were just
uncontrollable i think that was some of
the worst pain i've experienced in my
life
it's that cold and that's what narcan
does is it turns you cold that's why
when
people are narcan they wrap you up in
those heated blankets
because your body is immediately
withdrawing from
that heroin or the narcan or whatever or
the
fentanyl or whatever and that narcan is
trying to sober you up
man the next day i tried everything i
could to get high
and i just couldn't i was sober as [ __ ]
i couldn't get high for the life of me i
think i spent about a hundred dollars
that day
trying to get high nothing
no high whatsoever i mean i had some of
the best [ __ ] i had in my life and
nothing touched me because that narcan
was running through my system
[Music]
man it sucked i wasn't going through
with her also i was sober
you know like normal and it was weird
but uh
yeah and today you're living in a tent
on a skid row
yeah i live in a tent
down on sixth and wall
it's right by a gutter on our sidewalk
with uh this guy um
i won't say his name but uh you know
he's uh he looks out for me he takes
care of me
he makes sure i have my fix every day
and if i stay there you know
that's my man i guess
but i mean he protects me he takes care
of me so
it's better than being outside on the
sidewalk
i mean i'm technically on a sidewalk but
at least there's a couch in there
you know i'm warm at night so it's
better than being completely stuck
outside
you know it's
better than nothing
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your 20 years
listen listen to the people that are
trying to help you
because that's all they're trying to do
they ain't trying to boss you around
they ain't trying to tell you how to
live they're just trying to give you the
right ways to live
most times you know just listen to the
ones that are stable
the ones that have a house the ones that
have a job
listen to them because they can't help
you
i mean i'm lucky i came across you
because [ __ ] if i didn't i don't know
what i would have had to do for money
today
i mean that's all i've got to survive on
you know
but uh
yeah that's me
all right miranda thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
i wish you the best of luck in getting
off these streets getting away from
thank you all right thank you